So a little while back, this guy named Ken Irwin started reaching out to people here at This American Life. Emanuele got a voicemail that was both very insistent and deeply apologetic.
不久前，一个名叫肯·欧文（Ken Irwin）的人开始联系我们《美国生活》（This American Life）的同事。伊曼纽尔（Emanuele）收到了一条语音留言，对方既显得非常急切，又语气诚恳地连连道歉。
Hi, I'm so sorry for calling you. I'm just trying to get ahold of someone at This American Life or New York Times. I'm so sorry for interrupting you on your weekend.
嗨，很抱歉打扰你。我只是想联系一下《美国生活》或者《纽约时报》的人。很抱歉在周末打扰你，真的非常抱歉。
Chloee got messages on LinkedIn saying, quote, "If you can give me five minutes to tell you what I know so far, I promise it's a crazy story."
克洛伊（Chloee）在领英（LinkedIn）上也收到了他的信息，上面写着：“如果你能给我五分钟告诉我你目前所知道的情况，我保证这是一个疯狂的故事。”
And today is about to be a million times crazier. Two weeks ago, my life was normal. I literally was just working for Amazon. I was a normal person.
而今天，这个故事将变得更加疯狂千万倍。两周前，我的生活还很正常。我当时就在亚马逊工作。我只是个普通人。
On Dana's voicemail, he said he was sure she was way too busy to call back herself. But he swore a factchecker could confirm everything he's saying.
在达纳（Dana）的语音留言里，他说他肯定她太忙了，没法亲自回电。但他发誓，会有事实核查员能证实他所说的一切。
Basically, I became a multimillionaire over the last week and a half, which is insane. And the story is so much crazier than what I'm even saying.
基本上，我在过去的一周半里变成了一个千万富翁，这太疯狂了。而且这个故事比我刚才说的还要疯狂得多。
To Brian, this guy wrote on Twitter, "I have no idea where the story will go as I'm stuck in it trying to figure it out. But I think you're exactly the type of person that could figure it out. So they all passed that information to me.
至于布莱恩（Brian），这家伙在推特上写道：“我不知道这个故事会走向何方，因为我正深陷其中，试图理清头绪。但我认为你正是那种能把它搞明白的人。”于是他们都把这些信息转给了我。
[RINGTONE]
[铃声]
Then I called the guy.
然后我给那个人打了电话。
Hi, this is Ken.
嗨，我是肯。
Hey, Ken. This is Ira Glass from This American Life.
嘿，肯。我是《美国生活》的艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Oh my god. That is amazing. Hi.
天哪。太不可思议了。你好。
Hi.
你好。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Thank you for calling. I did not expect to be talking to you. I'm so sorry for spamming your entire company.
谢谢你回电。我没想到能和你通话。对于给你们整个公司发垃圾信息，我深表歉意。
Right off the bat, he asked me if I knew what NFTs are. And I had a general idea that they're images and other things in the crypto world that people are selling to each other for a lot of money. For now, can I say, that's all you need to know for this to make sense.
一上来，他就问我知不知道什么是NFT。我当时有个大概的了解，知道它们是加密货币世界里的图像或其他东西，人们正以高价互相买卖。暂时来说，我可以这么说，这就是你需要了解的全部，这样下面的内容才讲得通。
He told me that this all began for him two weeks before our conversation on August 22nd.
他告诉我，这一切对他来说始于我们谈话前两周，即8月22日。
So the person named Adam McBride reached out. If you Google him, he calls himself an NFT archaeologist. I don't know how to describe him. He has a podcast.
有一个叫亚当·麦克布莱德（Adam McBride）的人联系了他。如果你在谷歌上搜他，会发现他自称是“NFT考古学家”。我不知道该怎么描述他。他有个播客。
So he reached on LinkedIn and Gmail and basically told me, hey, if you're the owner of PixelMap, I need to talk to you immediately.
他在领英和Gmail上联系我，基本上就是跟我说：嘿，如果你是PixelMap的拥有者，我需要立刻和你谈谈。
PixelMap was a website that Ken created in 2016.
PixelMap是肯在2016年创建的一个网站。
He wants to tell me that basically, I could make a lot of money if I brought the site back up. And I immediately assumed he was scamming me. Because we all get emails like that all the time.
他想告诉我，基本上，如果我把网站重新上线，我能赚很多钱。我立刻以为他在诈骗我。因为我们总是收到那样的邮件。
And the only reason I talked to him was he mentioned PixelMap. The site has been down literally since 2017. So I just wanted to know how he even knew that word.
我之所以愿意和他谈，唯一的原因是他提到了PixelMap。那个网站实际上从2017年起就瘫痪了。所以我只是想知道他到底是怎么知道那个词的。
Ken has made PixelMap just for fun and to teach himself a new programming language. He's somebody who was always tinkering, inventing things, a hovercraft that could carry a dog. He has three dachshunds and a fourth dog that he refers to as the randomly generated dog.
肯制作PixelMap只是为了好玩，顺便自学一门新的编程语言。他一直是个喜欢修补、发明东西的人，比如他发明过一艘能载狗的汽垫船。他有三只腊肠犬，还有第四只狗，他称之为“随机生成的狗”。
One of his recent projects, he used a 3D printer to create another, better 3D printer. His real job was he worked for Amazon's web services company. He was one of the lead engineers developing code for big companies like Snapchat and Pinterest. He's 33, lives in Indiana.
他最近的项目之一是用一台3D打印机制造了另一台更好的3D打印机。他的正职是在亚马逊的云服务公司工作。他是开发Snapchat和Pinterest等大公司代码的首席工程师之一。他33岁，住在印第安纳州。
As for PixelMap--
关于PixelMap——
You can see it. Actually, you're going to think it looks stupid, probably. But-- [LAUGHS]
你可以看一看。说实话，你可能会觉得它看起来很蠢。但是—— [笑声]
This is the kind of self-deprecating remark I've learned that Ken does reflexively a lot. But in this case, the PixelMap.io website does look kind of primitive when you first see it, like early 8-bit Nintendo or something. It's a grid of tiles, a picture of 4,000 little tiles, and they're tiny. Each is 16 by 16 pixels.
这就是我所了解到的肯习惯性的自我调侃。但在这种情况下，当你第一次看到PixelMap.io网站时，它看起来确实有点原始，就像早期的8位任天堂游戏一样。它是一个瓷砖网格，由4000个小瓷砖组成的图片，它们非常小。每个瓷砖只有16x16像素。
And the idea is anybody can buy the tiles, own them, and decorate them how they want. So people have different cartoons in them and words they've posted. When Ken created this back in 2016, barely anybody noticed or cared. Maybe 20 or 30 people bought tiles. Within a year, he was pretty much done with PixelMap.
它的理念是任何人都可以购买瓷砖，拥有它们，并按照自己的意愿进行装饰。所以人们在里面贴了各种卡通画和文字。当肯在2016年创建它时，几乎没人注意到或关心。可能也就20或30个人买了瓷砖。一年之内，他基本上就不再管PixelMap了。
So that is the project that this guy Adam McBride wanted to talk to him about. And so the same day that Ken gets Adam's email, that afternoon, he gets on a Zoom with him.
所以这就是亚当·麦克布莱德想和他谈的那个项目。就在肯收到亚当邮件的当天下午，他就和对方进行了Zoom会议。
He said basically what he does is he goes in and tries to find really old NFT projects and that he does it as a hobby and really enjoys doing it. And he said that mine would be one of the earliest, even though 2016 is not that long ago. In the NFT space, that's almost the oldest you can go. And that I'm probably sitting on a ton of money and I don't realize it.
他说，他所做的工作基本上就是去寻找非常古老的NFT项目，他把这当作一种业余爱好，并且非常乐在其中。他说我的项目可能是最早的之一，尽管2016年离现在并不久。但在NFT领域，这几乎是最古老的项目了。他还说我可能正坐拥巨额财富而不自知。
Sitting on a ton of money because in the crypto world, one kind of NFT that people get excited about and pay money for is what they call historic NFTs, the first NFTs that ever existed. Ken tells Adam that's all great, what's an NFT? Adam give him a quick primer.
坐拥巨额财富，因为在加密货币世界里，有一种NFT让人们很兴奋并愿意花钱购买，那就是所谓的“历史性NFT”，即有史以来最早的NFT。肯问亚当：那很好，什么是NFT？亚当给了他一个简短的入门介绍。
And had it ever occurred to you that what you had made was an NFT?
你有没有想过，你所创造的东西其实是一个NFT？
No, because when I made it, there were no NFTs. The only time I had heard of NFT since then, I had heard in the news that Steph Curry had one. And I really hadn't even looked to see what an NFT was, which I know sounds really stupid. I had truly completely forgotten about my site.
没有，因为我创作的时候，根本没有NFT这回事。从那以后我唯一一次听说NFT是在新闻里看到斯蒂芬·库里（Steph Curry）拥有一个。我甚至都没去查过NFT到底是什么，我知道这听起来很蠢。我真的已经完全忘了我的网站了。
And I was saying, how much do you think I could get for it? And he said, I've seen projects like this. I had one that the developer got over 100,000. But looking at yours, I think you could probably get 500 grand out of it.
我当时问他，你觉得我能卖多少钱？他说，我见过类似的项目。有一个开发者卖了超过10万。但看着你的项目，我觉得你可能能赚到50万。
And at that point, I thought he was really nice. I didn't think there was any chance on earth of that actually happening. [LAUGHS]
在那一刻，我觉得他真的很不错。我根本没想过这事儿真的会发生。 [笑声]
Adam McBride tells him, I can help you set this up and get it relaunched, and people will pay you gobs of money for the rest of those 4,000 tiles. He said he knows a group of guys who love the early historic NFTs, like this one. And they'll all talk it up on Twitter. They'll encourage people to buy. He says he's done this for a bunch of other old NFTs.
亚当·麦克布莱德告诉他：我可以帮你设置好一切，重新发布它，人们会为你剩下的那4000个瓷砖支付大把钞票。他说他认识一群喜欢早期历史性NFT的人，就像这个项目一样。他们会在推特上大肆宣传。他们会鼓励人们购买。他说他已经为其他很多老式NFT做过这件事了。
But Adam tells him there was one little snag. Ken needs to lower the price of each tile. That's because back in 2016, Ken set the price of each tile at 2 Ether. Now, Ether-- I didn't know anything about this. Ken I to explain this to me-- is the name of one of the big cryptocurrencies, like Bitcoin. And 2 Ether back in 2016 was around 20 bucks. The problem, Adam explained, was the value of Ether had blown up. And 2 Ether these days was now more than $6,000, way too high for most people.
但亚当告诉他有一个小障碍。肯需要降低每个瓷砖的价格。因为早在2016年，肯把每个瓷砖的价格定为2以太币（Ether）。现在，以太币——我对这个一无所知，肯得向我解释——是像比特币一样的主流加密货币之一。2016年的2以太币价值约为20美元。亚当解释说，问题在于以太币的价值已经暴涨了。现在的2以太币价值已经超过6000美元，这对大多数人来说太高了。
He said I would be a lot better off and a lot more successful if I would set all of them to 0.35 Eth.
他说如果我把所有瓷砖的价格都设为0.35以太币，我会过得更好，也会更成功。
0.35 Eth. In other words, each image would cost 0.35 Ether, a third of an Ether-- at the time, around $1,000.
0.35以太币。换句话说，每张图像的价格为0.35以太币，也就是三分之一个以太币——当时大约是1000美元。
And for me, that made complete sense.
对我来说，这完全说得通。
He told me he didn't really believe any of this was going to work anyway. But he figured, what's he got to lose?
他告诉我，他其实根本不相信这一切会成功。但他心想，反正也没什么可损失的？
So I'm just like, I'll go with it.
所以我就是想，那就试试吧。
So Ken started knocking down the price of his 4,000 tiles, which actually took some time. Because the way he wrote the original code, the original program for PixelMap, repricing each tile took a few minutes. And had to do them by hand one at a time for hundreds and hundreds of tiles.
于是肯开始降低他的4000个瓷砖的价格，这其实花了不少时间。因为他编写原始代码的方式，即PixelMap的原始程序，修改每个瓷砖的价格需要几分钟。他不得不为成百上千个瓷砖一个个手动操作。
Now, he could have written code to automate that process. But he said he wasn't thinking straight that particular week. Because that week, his dad had a heart attack and went to the hospital for bypass surgery. And so Ken was spending a lot of time at the hospital with his dad.
其实他本可以写一段代码来自动化这个过程。但他那天头脑不太清醒。因为那一周，他父亲心脏病发作并住院进行了搭桥手术。所以肯花了很多时间在医院陪他父亲。
Adam was sending messages to the buyers, who were, quote, "pounding at the door." Hurry up, do them faster. And some people were so impatient, they just paid the higher price, over $6,000 2 Ether, which leads to an obvious question.
亚当一直在给买家发信息，说他们“正在疯狂抢购”。快点，弄快点。有些买家太没耐心，直接支付了更高的价格，即超过6000美元的2以太币，这就引出了一个显而易见的问题。
Why lower the price if people were paying 2 Ethereum for them?
既然人们愿意支付2以太币，为什么要降价呢？
Because I'm a moron. And he said that the whole reason that he was doing this big campaign-- I have no idea. My wife-- she's not my wife, but I've been with her for 11 years. She basically was like, if they're buying them at this, shouldn't we raise the price to 0.5 or 1 or just leave it at 2? Like, it looks like they want it.
因为我就是个白痴。他说他进行这场大营销的全部原因——我不知道。我的妻子——其实她不是我妻子，但我们在一起11年了。她基本上觉得，如果他们愿意按这个价格买，我们不是应该把价格提高到0.5或1，或者干脆保持2不变吗？看起来他们很想要。
And I was like, no. It was not smart. It was--
我却说：不。那不聪明。那简直是——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I was worried that-- what if they all of a sudden disappear or change their mind? I have no idea like why they want it, what's going on. All I know is if we sell them right now, I had done the math. I was like, we're looking at 2 million or more if we sell all of them.
我当时担心的是——如果他们突然消失或改变主意了怎么办？我完全不知道为什么他们想要它，发生了什么。我只知道如果现在卖掉，我算过这笔账。我当时想，如果我们全部卖掉，我们将获得200万甚至更多。
And I've never had that kind of money. Literally, all I could think about was like, I'm about to become a millionaire. And then the weird part of the story started happening.
我从来没见过那么多钱。我脑子里唯一能想到的就是：我马上要成为百万富翁了。然后这个故事诡异的部分就开始发生了。
Wait, wait, the weird part of the story hasn't even happened yet?
等等，等等，故事诡异的部分还没发生吗？
Correct, yes.
没错，是的。
What transpired next, he got a phone call that made him rethink everything that had happened to this point and look very differently at this guy Adam McBride, who seemed so nice and helpful at first. He and I had a series of conversations over the course of weeks where all of this unfolded.
接下来发生的事情是，他接到了一通电话，让他重新审视到目前为止发生的一切，并用完全不同的眼光看待亚当·麦克布莱德这个起初看起来既友善又乐于助人的家伙。在接下来的几周里，我们进行了一系列对话，整个事情才慢慢揭开。
Basically, Ken started off like most of us, I think. He hadn't been following this whole NFT thing, didn't know what they were. And then suddenly, like, I don't know, somebody in a fairy tale who's transported to a strange new world where he learns he's a prince or a knight or something, Ken gets pulled into this crypto world where he finds he has all this cred, all this street cred as one of the first pioneers.
基本上，肯起初就像我们大多数人一样。他没关注过NFT这回事，不知道它们是什么。然后突然间，就像童话里那些被传送到奇异新世界的人，发现自己竟是王子或骑士，肯被拉进了这个加密世界，发现自己作为最早的先驱之一竟拥有如此高的声望。
And once he's there, he starts to take a look around at the NFT world, sort of dazed. Like, OK, you just made me a millionaire. Who are you people? And he does not like what he sees. And then some other things happen after that, which you'll hear.
一旦进入那里，他开始晕乎乎地环顾四周。就像是：好吧，你刚刚让我成了百万富翁。你们到底是什么人？然后他不喜欢他所看到的一切。在那之后还发生了一些别的事情，你会听到的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Seriously, stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听，别走开。
Act One, Planet of the Apes. OK, so Ken repriced his tiles, and things went even better than Adam McBride said they might. He sold 3,000 tiles, earning him a total of $3.5 million.
第一幕：人猿星球。好的，所以肯调整了他的瓷砖价格，事情的发展甚至比亚当·麦克布莱德说的还要好。他卖出了3000个瓷砖，总共赚了350万美元。
And the amount of time that took from Adam's first email to $3.5 million, two days and six hours. Six days after that, basically the first Monday that rolled around after he had all that money, he did what many people dream of doing if they hit the lottery or something. He quit his job.
而从亚当的第一封邮件到赚到这350万美元，只用了两天零六个小时。六天后，也就是他拿到那笔钱后的第一个周一，他做了许多人中了彩票后梦寐以求的事。他辞职了。
Not that he disliked his job. Just the opposite, he says. He really enjoyed his job. But he wanted to devote his time to developing PixelMap in various ways.
并不是他不爱自己的工作。正好相反，他说他非常喜欢。但他想全身心投入到以各种方式开发PixelMap的工作中。
Demand had pushed the price of PixelMap so high, $15,000 to $18,000 per tile. He decided to keep 900 of them for himself.
市场的需求把PixelMap的价格推得极高，每个瓷砖达到了1.5万到1.8万美元。他决定留下900个给自己。
But that's-- I'm not at the weird part of the story yet.
但那——还没到故事诡异的部分。
OK. All right, so let's get to the weird part of the story.
好的。好吧，那让我们进入故事诡异的部分。
So the weird part-- I mean, it's all weird. But the part that changed that was this guy reached out to me and basically said, hey, I've seen some things concerning on the transactions of PixelMap. I wanted to reach out and see if I can talk to you about it. And he sounded like he was ticked off.
诡异的部分——我是说，这一切都很诡异。但发生改变的那部分是，有个人联系了我，基本意思是：嘿，我看到关于PixelMap交易的一些令人担忧的事。我想找你聊聊。听起来他很生气。
So I was like, sure. I called him. I've been talking to him literally every day since then.
所以我说：没问题。我给他打了电话。从那以后，我几乎每天都和他通话。
The guy was calling from Australia. He told him he'd been looking at all the PixelMap sales, which is not something that's hard to do. Because every transaction with NFTs and with crypto is all public. That's how crypto works.
那个人是从澳大利亚打来的。他告诉肯，他一直在查看所有的PixelMap销售记录，这并不难做到。因为NFT和加密货币的每一笔交易都是公开的。这就是加密货币的运作方式。
And this guy was looking at the transactions, and the whole thing looked fishy to him. Why, he asked, were you lowering the price of all the tiles when demand for them was so high? He said he didn't know exactly what kind of ripoff Ken was running, but it made no sense.
那个人查看了交易记录，整件事在他看来显得很可疑。他问：为什么在需求如此高涨时，你还要降低所有瓷砖的价格？他说他不知道肯在玩什么把戏，但这根本说不通。
He was positive it had to be a scam, or else I was a complete moron, like that's the only two options. And I was like, I think I might be a moron then.
他肯定这要么是诈骗，要么就是我是个彻头彻尾的白痴，只有这两种可能。我当时想：那我也许真是个白痴。
And then he told me about CryptoPunks.
然后他告诉了我CryptoPunks。
OK, CryptoPunks. CryptoPunks are this big iconic NFT. And they're these little cartoons. They're like punks, like '80s punks with mohawks or dyed hair, all of them slightly different.
好的，CryptoPunks。CryptoPunks是一个非常标志性的NFT项目。它们是一些小卡通。就像朋克，80年代的朋克，留着莫霍克发型或染着头发，每个人都略有不同。
There are 10,000 of them. Cute, easy to understand, and they caught on. Celebrities bought them, Jay-Z, Serena Williams, Heidi Klum, Snoop Dogg. And a big part of their value supposedly was that they were among the earliest NFTs anyone ever made.
一共有一万个。可爱，易于理解，并且流行起来了。名人们买了它们，比如Jay-Z、小威廉姆斯、海蒂·克鲁姆、史努比狗狗。它们价值中很大一部分被认为是它们是有史以来最早的NFT之一。
And they were marketed that way, as the original NFT, the first NFT. The average price of a CryptoPunk when Ken was talking to the guy in Australia, $300,000 to $400,000 each. Each!
它们就是以此作为卖点的，号称是原始NFT，第一个NFT。在肯和那个澳大利亚人通话时，CryptoPunks的平均价格是每个30万到40万美元。每个！
Guy in Australia was like, PixelMap is a year older than CryptoPunks. And so--
那个澳大利亚人说：PixelMap比CryptoPunks还要早一年。所以——
There's absolutely no reason why yours wouldn't be worth even more than that. You're sitting on not a couple of million, most likely several hundred million, unless you keep screwing up, essentially. But he said that with, like, Australian words, which are less friendly.
完全没有理由说你的东西不值那个价。你坐拥的不仅仅是几百万，很可能是几亿，除非你不断犯傻。但他用了一些澳大利亚词汇，听起来没那么友好。
What were the words he used?
他用了什么词？
Like, you need to stop being a fucking idiot.
比如：你得停止当个他妈的白痴了。
The guy from Australia said it didn't make sense to lower PixelMap's price at all. Again, CryptoPunks are selling for $400,000. And Ken was reducing PixelMap to $1,000. And the guy in Australia had a prime suspect for who might be benefiting most from this odd behavior, for who might be behind all of it.
那个澳大利亚人说，降低PixelMap的价格根本说不通。再说一次，CryptoPunks都能卖到40万美元。而肯却把PixelMap降到了1000美元。而那个澳大利亚人有一个头号怀疑对象，怀疑是谁从这种奇怪的行为中获利最多，怀疑是谁在幕后操纵这一切。
There was a bot, a bot that purchased 1,000 PixelMap tiles at the lowest price and then watched the price double and double again and again and again. The bot, the bot was the biggest owner of PixelMap. Whoever was behind the bot had made a ton of money.
有个机器人（Bot），一个机器人购买了1000个PixelMap瓷砖，还是在最低价格时买入的，然后眼睁睁看着价格翻倍、翻倍、又翻倍。那个机器人是PixelMap最大的持有人。不管是谁在幕后操纵那个机器人，都已经赚翻了。
I remember him saying, who do you think owns the bot?
我记得他问我：你觉得是谁拥有那个机器人？
Ken's first thought, Adam McBride. After all, it was Adam McBride who talked him into doing this illogical thing of lowering the price. But then he thought, did Adam McBride have that kind of money? 1,000 tiles cost more than a million dollars.
肯的第一个念头是：亚当·麦克布莱德。毕竟，是亚当·麦克布莱德说服他去做降低价格这种不合逻辑的事。但后来他又想：亚当·麦克布莱德有那么多钱吗？1000个瓷砖的成本超过一百万美元。
So he had another suspect, a rich guy, somebody who could be the money behind Adam McBride. And I just want to say, I know that this is a very random name to be pulling out of the air and putting into the story.
所以他有了另一个嫌疑人，一个有钱人，一个可能是亚当·麦克布莱德背后的金主。我只想说，我知道随便拉出一个名字塞进故事里听起来很随机。
But the rich guy Ken suspected was the president of the Philadelphia 76ers, Daryl Morey. Daryl Morey who very publicly has talked about loving NFTs, and who Ken suspected because Adam showed him that Morey had bought a few tiles of PixelMap very early, even before Adam relaunched the site officially, before Adam told the world about it.
但肯怀疑的那个有钱人是费城76人队的总裁达里尔·莫雷（Daryl Morey）。达里尔·莫雷公开表示过他热爱NFT，肯之所以怀疑他，是因为亚当给肯展示过，莫雷在PixelMap网站正式重启之前，甚至在亚当向全世界公布之前，就已经很早就买入了一些瓷砖。
How did he know to do that? Maybe he also created the bot to quietly snag an extra 1,000 tiles.
他怎么会知道要那么做？也许他就是那个机器人的创造者，悄悄抢走了额外的1000个瓷砖。
So I'm almost certain that it's either Adam or Daryl or a combination that got those. I am trying to prove it. But I don't know for sure. It's just literally, those are the only two that would have known that early on. Because the thousand were basically right at the very beginning.
所以我几乎确定这要么是亚当，要么是达里尔，或者是他们俩合伙搞的。我正在努力证明这一点。但我还不确定。字面上说，只有他们俩才知道得那么早。因为那一千个瓷砖基本上就是在最开始的时候买走的。
And they had a right to get it. But Adam told me-- he was specifically telling me the only way it would work is if I-- and I sound like a moron right now even saying this-- but to lower the price and making the mil as fast as possible.
他们确实有权购买。但亚当告诉我的——他专门告诉我，唯一能成功的方法就是我——说这话我都觉得自己像个白痴——就是要尽可能快地降价并赚到第一桶金。
I don't want to be rude, but it sounds like Adam probably asked you to lower the price so he could buy more of them. Because he knew the price was going to go up.
我不想粗鲁，但听起来亚当可能是想让你降低价格，这样他就能买更多。因为他知道价格会涨。
Yes. And he got 1,000 of them.
是的。他买了一千个。
So have you asked Adam?
那你问过亚当吗？
No.
没有。
Why not?
为什么不问？
So I'm basically still playing the stupid card because I'm trying to get proof of it. There is the 0.01% chance that he didn't do-- I don't even know how it would be possible that it's not him. But I want to know if it's him, or if it's him and Daryl, or who it is.
因为我基本上还在装傻，因为我想拿到证据。有0.01%的可能不是他——我甚至不知道怎么可能不是他。但我得知道到底是不是他，还是他和达里尔，又或者到底是谁。
Ken, can I ask you, why be so mad at Adam? You didn't know what you had. He let you know. He made you a millionaire. And he's also on the internet making the market for you. He's actually finding buyers for you. He's talking it up. He's making the whole thing happen. Why shouldn't he make money? Like, who cares he owns 1,000 of them? You own 900 of them, and you'll make a lot of money.
肯，我可以问你，为什么要对亚当那么生气？你本来不知道你拥有的是什么。是他让你知道的。是他让你成了百万富翁。而且他还在互联网上为你建立市场。他实际上是在帮你找买家。他在为你宣传。他让这一切都发生了。他赚点钱又有什么关系？谁在乎他拥有1000个瓷砖？你自己还有900个，你也赚了很多钱。
You sound like my wife. So [LAUGHS] no, so two reasons. And one, I gave him a half million dollars as a thank you, because I went full moron. I cannot tell you how bad that sucks that I did that. But I am just adding that to the story.
你听起来简直和我妻子一模一样。所以 [笑声] 不，我有两个原因。第一，我给了他五十万美元作为感谢，因为我当时完全像个白痴。我没法告诉你我做那件事有多后悔。但我只是把它加进故事里。
OK, OK.
好吧，好吧。
But the other part of that, though, was when he was talking to me the first day, he told me, I'm not-- because I was like, there has to be something in it for you. Why would you just do this?
但这其中的另一部分是，当他在第一天跟我谈话时，他告诉我——因为我当时问：你总得从中得到点什么吧。你为什么要这么做？
And he told me he's basically doing it because he enjoys making people happy. And if I want to reward him at the end of it, I can. If not, he just likes to do it. So part of it is him just lying outright and grabbing the thousand.
他告诉我，他基本上这么做是因为他喜欢让别人开心。如果我最后想回报他，可以。如果不回报，他就是喜欢做这件事。所以其中一部分是他完全在撒谎，然后顺便抢走了那一千个瓷砖。
It's more about him just lying to me. It's just not nice.
比起这个，更多的是他骗了我。这太不厚道了。
It was galling and sort of mindbending this guy who'd seemed like such a pal, so supportive, could have been playing him for a sucker all along, ripping him off at the exact moment he was making Ken richer than he'd ever imagined he'd be.
这让人感到恼火，而且有些不可思议。这个曾经看起来像朋友、如此支持他的人，竟然一直把他当作冤大头来玩弄，在他让自己变得比想象中还要富有的时候，竟然在背地里宰了他一笔。
You don't have to know much about crypto to know that it is rife with scams of all kinds. Ken wanted to figure out who was behind the bot. Because he wanted to understand, what had just happened to him?
你不需要懂太多加密货币知识就知道它充满了各种诈骗。肯想搞清楚是谁在幕后操纵机器人。因为他想弄明白：刚才发生在他身上的到底是什么？
Was he like the rube who was so naive that he didn't even realize that his pocket was being picked? What was real and what was not in this new world he suddenly found himself in? We agreed to stay in touch.
他难道是个傻瓜，天真到连自己被掏了腰包都不知道吗？在他突然发现自己身处的新世界里，什么是真，什么是假？我们约定保持联系。
Four days later, Ken texts me saying there's news. And we get on the phone. It's September 11th, his birthday. We chat a little about how it's been kind of a weird birthday to have, most of his life.
四天后，肯发短信告诉我有了新情况。我们通了电话。那天是9月11日，也是他的生日。我们聊了一会儿在这个奇怪的生日那天会有什么感觉。
But that's not the news. He also has COVID, but it's a mild case. That's also not the news. And so what's new?
但这不是重点。他还得了新冠，不过是轻症。那也不是重点。所以，有什么新情况？
Well, he's been spending a lot of time trying to understand what's really happening with NFTs, especially with Adam McBride and the guys who buy these historic NFTs. And he's convinced it's pretty ugly.
嗯，他一直在花时间试图弄清楚NFT到底在发生什么，尤其是亚当·麦克布莱德和那些购买历史性NFT的人。他确信事情非常丑陋。
Yeah, it's not like a maybe. I have proof out the ass-- sorry for language. I have a lot of fucking proof. They are doing this actively, project after project. It's really fucking horrible what they're doing.
是的，这不是“可能”。我有铁证如山——对不起，用词粗俗了。我有他妈的很多证据。他们正在积极地策划，一个项目接一个项目。他们做的事情简直太他妈恶劣了。
I don't think it's illegal. I'm not saying any of it's illegal. I think it's hugely wrong and unethical, but there's no laws about it. But honestly, this is coming from the person that made the second NFT, if I have it right. I don't think they should fucking exist.
我不认为这是违法的。我没说任何事情是违法的。我认为这极其错误且不道德，但目前没有相关法律。但老实说，这话出自那个创造了第二个NFT的人之口——如果我没记错的话。我不认为它们应该他妈的存在。
He means NFTs.
他指的是NFT。
I think it's a horrible scam that's screwing over people, the whole thing.
我认为这整个事情就是一个正在坑人的恶毒骗局。
Ken said that he sees everything that Adam McBride and his guys are doing because they've kind of adopted him and included him in their chat groups on Discord. Discord, if you don't know, is a chat site. Adam refers to the guys in his discord group as the apes.
肯说他能看到亚当·麦克布莱德和他的手下所做的一切，因为他们已经接纳了他，把他拉进了Discord的聊天群里。如果你不知道的话，Discord是一个聊天网站。亚当把Discord群里的人称为“猿群”（Apes）。
And I had no idea what an ape was, other than a monkey. It's just people that are ridiculously enthusiastic about NFTs. And when they find out about one, they just go in and grab them like crazy.
我除了知道猿是猴子的一种外，完全不知道“猿”在这里是什么意思。其实就是那些对NFT有着疯狂狂热的人。当他们发现一个项目时，就会像疯子一样涌进去抢购。
That's called aping in. Ape is a word that you actually hear a lot in the NFT world. One big NFT is the Bored Apes Yacht Club. To show me what is so horrible about what Adam's doing, Ken calls me back from his computer so he can share his screen.
这被称为“Aping in”（像猿一样涌入）。在NFT世界里你经常会听到“猿”这个词。一个巨大的NFT项目就是“无聊猿游艇俱乐部”（Bored Apes Yacht Club）。为了向我展示亚当所做的事情有多么恶劣，肯从电脑前给我回拨电话，以便分享他的屏幕。
Testing.
测试。
There we go.
好了。
Sorry it took me a while. My microphone wasn't plugged in.
抱歉耽误了点时间。我的麦克风没插好。
This is the moment I see him for the first time. He's clean-cut with short hair, neatly trimmed beard, and the general vibe of the friendliest, most sincere tech support guy in the world. For his job, he did his video calls in front of a green screen with a really nice microphone. And that's what he has in this call.
这是我第一次看到他。他面容整洁，短发，精心修剪的胡子，给人的感觉就像是世界上最友好、最真诚的技术支持人员。他的工作是在绿幕前进行视频通话，并配备了一支非常好的麦克风。在这次通话中他也是如此。
He goes to open up Adam's discord group, NFT Archaeologist.
他去打开亚当的Discord群组：“NFT考古学家”。
Here it is. So this just happened. So at 2:44 PM, just a few minutes ago, Adam said, "all right, everyone. Please do not tweet or send this out to anyone. I want to keep this opportunity to this community only."
在这儿。刚发生的事。下午2:44，就在几分钟前，亚当说：“好了，大家。请不要发推特或转发给任何人。我想把这个机会留在我们这个社区内部。”
And this is how he always does it. This is what he did with PixelMap. I just didn't know the group yet.
他总是这么干。他当时对PixelMap也是这么做的。我只是那时候还不认识这个群组的人。
What Adam McBride is doing right here is he is rolling out another one of these historic NFTs. This particular one is called Aether, A-E-T-H-E-R. It was created in 2018, two years after PixelMap. Like PixelMap, most people never noticed it back when it was created.
亚当·麦克布莱德现在所做的就是推出另一个历史性NFT。这个特别的NFT叫Aether（以太），A-E-T-H-E-R。它创建于2018年，比PixelMap晚两年。和PixelMap一样，它创建时大多数人从未注意过。
But now Adam's going to help relaunch it the way that Adam relaunched PixelMap. He'll get people to finally pay money for what are basically in this case virtual imaginary buildings in a virtual digital city.
但现在亚当要像重启PixelMap那样去重启它。他会让人们最终为那些在这个案例中本质上是虚拟的、想象中的数字城市建筑支付金钱。
Ken and I read the conversation that's happening in the chat. McBride is telling the apes, let's all buy into this and get out there on Twitter and tell everybody we know to buy it as well.
我和肯阅读了聊天室里的对话。麦克布莱德正在告诉“猿群”们，大家一起买入，然后去推特上告诉每一个认识的人也买入。
So he's basically saying, go crazy on Aether, Ether. I don't know how to say it.
所以他基本上就是说，在Aether上疯狂操作吧。我不知道怎么发音。
And to make this especially appealing to the apes, McBride says that he has negotiated with the guy who created Aether to offer Aether to his apes at a special low price, quote, "well below what I think they're going to sell for."
为了让这个项目对“猿群”们特别有吸引力，麦克布莱德说他已经和Aether的创造者协商过，以一个特别的低价提供给他的“猿群”们，称其“远低于我认为它们最终会卖出的价格”。
And to get the special low price, he tells them he's going to hold a live event on Discord at 9:00 AM Eastern time on Sunday. The apes respond, Adam, that's a fantastic opportunity for us all. Thanks for this, much appreciated. You're the GOAT, Adam.
为了得到这个特别的低价，他告诉他们，他将在周日上午9点（东部时间）在Discord上举办一场直播活动。“猿群”们回应道：亚当，这对我们大家来说是一个绝佳的机会。感谢你，感激不尽。亚当，你是最棒的（GOAT）。
Sunday's the next day. At 9:00 AM, the apes gather.
周日是第二天。上午9点，“猿群”们聚集在一起。
So get ready. It's coming up at any second here, OK?
所以准备好了。任何时候都会开始，好吗？
That right there is the voice of Adam McBride in the Discord. You hear him, but you do not see him. You see his screenshare as he clicks on various stuff.
刚才那是亚当·麦克布莱德在Discord里的声音。你能听见他，但看不见他。你看到的是他点击各种东西时的共享屏幕。
And to give you a sense of the very happy Let's Make a Deal, take a look at what's behind the curtain vibe of the whole thing, here is the moment when he gave 50 of his apes the chance to sign up to buy Aether on the cheap for around $340. He told the apes a sign-up sheet was about to go live.
为了让你感受到那种“让我们做笔交易吧”的极度快乐，以及“看看幕后有什么”的氛围，这里就是他给50个“猿群”成员机会，让他们以约340美元的便宜价格认购Aether的那一刻。他告诉“猿群”成员，注册表马上就要上线了。
I am going to, in the next minute or so, make that public. And the first 50 of you guys who paste your name in there, we're going to give you a private sale link. So get ready. Get your stuff ready. I hope you're all ready right now. Be ready.
我将在接下来的一分钟左右让它公开。你们中前50个把名字粘贴进去的人，我们将给你们一个私人购买链接。所以准备好了。把你们的东西准备好。我希望你们现在都准备好了。准备好。
So at some point in the next seconds, you guys tell me if you see the-- oh my god. Boom, ape-age.
所以接下来几秒钟内的某个时刻，你们告诉我，如果你们看到了——天哪。砰，猿群涌入了。
The sign-up has appeared, names start filling in.
注册表出现了，名字开始填满。
You guys are fast. I see my man Curio Collector got in there. Let's see who else got in the top for sure. Chibbers got in there. Ugly Punky got in there for sure. Bottom Bally, nice. Space Llama, good to see you, brother. He got in there for sure.
你们真快。我看到我的哥们Curio Collector进去了。让我们看看还有谁进了前列。Chibbers进去了。Ugly Punky进去了。Bottom Bally，不错。Space Llama，很高兴见到你，兄弟。他肯定进去了。
I wanted to have some sort of ape-age possible. I think ape-age is always appreciated and fun. Man, I hope you guys enjoyed this. I definitely, I always enjoy this stuff. And of course, I'm always available--
我本来想搞点猿群涌入式的氛围。我觉得“猿群涌入”总是很受欢迎且有趣。伙计，我希望你们享受这次机会。我肯定，我总是很享受这些东西。当然，我也随时待命——
All this stuff that Adam McBride did, it was effective. It pushed up the price of Aether. At some point in this, Ken took me to a site called Opensea, which is the big trading platform where people buy and sell NFTs. And we watch as the apes descend from the trees and grab Aether.
亚当·麦克布莱德做的这一切非常有效。它推高了Aether的价格。在过程中的某个时候，肯带我去了Opensea网站，这是人们买卖NFT的大型交易平台，我们看着“猿群”们从树上降下来，开始抢购Aether。
Yeah. So see where it says-- see, two minutes, three minutes, four minutes, and see the price is going up. It was 0.14 or whatever. There's one that just went for 3.9. I guarantee it's going to be going crazy. By this evening, it's going to be crazy.
是的。看到那儿写的没——看，两分钟，三分钟，四分钟，看价格正在上涨。之前是0.14或者别的什么。刚才有一个成交价是3.9。我保证它会疯狂起来的。到今天晚上，它会变得疯狂。
Actually, right now you should go buy Aether. Because it's about to go up. [LAUGHS] Yeah. I'm not saying to do that, but yeah, that's what's going to happen shortly.
事实上，现在你应该去买Aether。因为它马上就要涨了。 [笑声] 是的。我不是在建议你这么做，但是的，不久之后就会那样。
I have to say, it is kind of amazing sitting there watching the numbers go up, knowing that this was as close to a sure thing as I would ever get. It was like free money, right there. But I didn't buy anything.
我不得不说，坐在那里看着数字不断跳动，知道这几乎是我能遇到的最确定的事情，这确实挺令人震惊的。就像是免费的钱，就在那儿。但我什么也没买。
By Monday, the average price of Aether had risen from $2,000 to $5,000. That's in one day, it more than doubled. And it also meant that the 50 apes who signed up on Adam's list for the special low price of $340, each of them now owned something worth $5,000.
到了周一，Aether的平均价格已经从2000美元涨到了5000美元。那是一天之内，价格翻了一倍多。这也意味着在亚当的名单上以340美元的特别低价注册的那50个“猿群”成员，他们每个人现在持有的东西价值5000美元。
A little higher, yeah, a little bit better.
再高一点，是的，再好一点。
So those guys could just get out and they'll have just made out like bandits already.
所以那些人只要出手，就已经像强盗一样发财了。
Yes, yeah.
是的，是的。
So what Adam's doing is working.
所以亚当所做的事情奏效了。
Yes.
是的。
You just literally kind of rolled your eyes.
你刚才字面意义上翻了个白眼。
No matter-- so the reason that I rolled my eyes is because it's a zero-sum thing. So someone's making money, no matter what. And when they do, that means someone's losing money.
无论如何——我翻白眼的原因是因为这是一个零和游戏。所以不管怎样，有人赚钱，就意味着有人亏钱。
And basically, the earlier you are, the better it is. If you know news before other people, basically, if you're one of these people, you're going to make out really well.
基本上，你越早介入，情况就越好。如果你比别人先得到消息，基本上，如果你是这些人中的一员，你会赚得很爽。
And lots of other people, Ken believes, will lose money. What we're seeing in his view is a classic pump and dump, something that if you did it in the stock market would be totally illegal. The apes get in early, talk up Aether on Twitter, encourage other people to buy, which pushes up the price. And in a couple of days when the price is at the highest, they sell, taking a quick and sizeable profit.
而肯认为，还有很多人会亏钱。在他看来，我们所看到的是一个典型的“拉高出货”（pump and dump），如果在股票市场上这样做是完全违法的。“猿群”们尽早介入，在推特上炒作Aether，鼓励其他人购买，从而推高价格。几天后，当价格达到最高点时，他们就卖出，赚取一笔可观的快钱。
Without the hype, the NFTs price falls. And anybody left holding it takes a beating, loses money. In fact today, in the months since that day when Adam relaunched Aether, the price has plummeted. It's now down as low as $900 some days, very different from those early, booming days when it was $5,000.
没有了炒作，NFT的价格就会下跌。任何最终持有人都会遭受打击，亏损资金。事实上，在亚当重启Aether的那天起，过去的几个月里，价格已经暴跌。现在有些日子甚至低至900美元，与早期那段5000美元的繁荣岁月大相径庭。
And I don't think as many people as you think are going to make the money. Like, every ape in here is probably going to do OK. But it's not going to be good for the people outside of it that hop on the train last.
我不认为会有你想象中那么多人能赚到钱。可能这个群里的每个“猿群”成员都会过得不错。但对于最后搭上这班车的局外人来说，情况就不会那么美好了。
And that's what Ken thinks is kind of evil about the world of NFTs, why he thinks they're a scam and shouldn't exist. Seeing all this made me wonder if any of this is actually illegal. And I've now talked to a bunch of lawyers about it, lawyers who deal with NFTs and crypto and security fraud, including two who advise companies that release NFTs.
这就是为什么肯认为NFT世界很邪恶，为什么他认为它们是骗局且不应该存在。目睹这一切让我不禁怀疑，这一切是否实际上是违法的。我已经找了几位律师谈过，他们是处理NFT、加密货币和证券欺诈的律师，其中包括两位为发行NFT的公司提供建议的律师。
And I described what I saw Adam McBride do in relaunching Aether. And all of them told me that NFTs are so new, the law is still pretty vague. There haven't been many lawsuits or much government enforcement in NFTs. But they pointed to two things that could be problematic.
我描述了我所看到的亚当·麦克布莱德在重启Aether时所做的一切。他们所有人都告诉我，NFT太新了，法律还非常模糊。在NFT领域还没出现多少诉讼或政府执法案例。但他们指出了两点可能存在问题的地方。
OK, first, if Adam and the apes were pumping and dumping-- specifically, if they were lying about Aether or about their own trading, that would be an issue. Like if they were going onto Twitter and telling people that Aether is a great investment, worth seeking money into for the long run, but then if they themselves only held onto it for a few days until the price rose and then they sold it, that would be illegal. That would be market manipulation.
好吧，第一，如果亚当和“猿群”们是在进行“拉高出货”——具体来说，如果他们在关于Aether或他们自己的交易上撒谎，那将是一个问题。就像如果他们去推特上告诉人们Aether是一项伟大的长期投资，值得投入资金，但他们自己却只持有了几天，等到价格上涨就卖掉，那就是违法的。那是市场操纵行为。
The second thing the lawyers pointed to, transparency is key. If Adam was going out giving a special price to 50 people to generate buzz and excitement, that is a normal kind of promotion in lots of industries, one of the lawyers says. He said that could be fine.
律师指出的第二件事是，透明度是关键。如果亚当出去给50个人一个特别价格以创造热度和兴奋感，这是一位律师所说的许多行业中常见的一种促销行为。他说那可能没问题。
But the key to that being OK is that Adam would need to disclose it all publicly so that any possible investor can find out that some people got a special cheaper price. If Adam didn't do that, he would be in danger of some investor, maybe somebody who lost money, later suing him over holding back that information.
但这一切没问题的关键在于，亚当需要公开披露这一切，以便任何可能的投资者都能发现有些人得到了特别的低价。如果亚当没这么做，他就有可能面临投资者的诉讼，也许是亏钱的人，后来因为他隐瞒了这些信息而起诉他。
OK, so was Adam crossing the line into illegality with either of those things? Ken still didn't have proof of that, either way.
好的，那么亚当是否在其中任何一点上越过了违法界限？肯仍然没有证据。
As for the bot, that mysterious bot that purchased 1,000 PixelMap tiles, a fourth of all the tiles, Ken started to worry that it was someone much more sinister than Adam behind the bot. One day he texts me panicked about what he's learning about the bot, so scared about it that he doesn't know if he wants to go on the radio anymore.
至于那个购买了1000个PixelMap瓷砖、占所有瓷砖四分之一的神秘机器人，肯开始担心在机器人背后是一个比亚当更险恶的人。有一天他惊慌失措地给我发短信，说他正在了解关于这个机器人的一些事，被吓坏了，以至于不知道自己是否还想上电台。
I guess the short part is just I'm kind of freaked out. It's just it's so much bigger than what I-- the bot account that I was telling you about is just much, much bigger.
我想简单点说就是我被吓坏了。它比我预想的——我跟你提过的那个机器人账号要大得多，非常大。
He sent me a screenshot that showed that the account had done nearly $2 billion in trades-- specifically, it's 1.84 billion-- since it was created 14 months before.
他给我发了一张截图，显示该账户自14个月前创建以来，交易额近20亿美元——确切地说是18.4亿。
This is not some normal person. This is a legitimately smart probably group of bad people. It's a very well-organized thing.
这绝非普通人。这是一个非常有组织、合法的、聪明的坏人集团。
You don't think it's possible that it's just a bunch of investors--
你不觉得可能只是这群投资者吗——
No.
不。
--like the group that--
——像那个——
No.
不。
--Adam has assembled around him where it's like--
——亚当在他周围聚集的那个群体，有100个人在一起有很多钱？
No.
不。
--100 people and together, they have a lot of money?
我不觉得他有那么老练——或者，是的，他可能是在为这个组织工作之类的。但我不觉得他聪明到能搞成这样。如果他有那么多钱，就不会做他正在做的事了。
I don't think he's sophisticated-- or, yes, he might be working for this group or something. But I don't think he's smart enough to be like this. He wouldn't be doing what he was doing if he had this much money.
这完全是不同量级的人。可能是像俄罗斯黑手党之类的人。我知道这听起来很荒谬。但这只是一个账号。有那么多钱并且从事这种行为的人，绝不会喜欢别人在电台上举报他们。
This is a totally different league of someone. It could be like, the Russian mafia or something. I know that sounds ridiculous. But this is only one account. People that have that much money and are doing that type of behavior are not into people blowing the whistle on them.
举报，他指的是在电台上公开谈论他们。
Blowing the whistle, he means talking about them publicly on the radio.
我不知道。没有哪部好电影里举报者能活到最后并过上幸福生活。通常结局是，像我这样的人会被杀掉。
I don't know. There are no good movies where the person that plays me makes it to the end and has like a happy life. It's usually like, the person that's like me gets killed.
等等，有很多举报者的电影，举报者活到了最后。
Wait, there are whistleblower movies where the whistleblower makes it to the end and lives.
我不知道。我字面上没有——我没有栅栏——即使有栅栏也挡不住什么。我——我住在印第安纳州。我可能是全州唯一没有枪的人。我真的觉得我的名字出现在这个故事里可能会导致我甚至我的家人消失。我真的有这种感觉。
I don't know. I literally don't have-- I don't have a fence-- not that a fence would stop anything. I have like, no-- I live in Indiana. I'm probably the only person that doesn't have a gun in the state. I seriously legitimately feel like my name being on a story could result in me not existing, or my family. I legitimately feel that way.
哇。
Wow.
我没有夸张。这就是我的感觉。
I'm not exaggerating. That's how I feel.
我在通话中，后来在邮件里告诉他，我尊重他的任何选择。当然，如果他退出这个故事也没关系。但他关于那18亿交易额的说法对吗？
I tell him on the call, and later in email, that I respect any choice he makes. And of course, it's fine if he drops out of the story. But is he right about that 1.8 billion in trades?
机器人会不会只是用少得多的钱进行了大量的交易？也许机器人甚至是在自己买卖来推高NFT的价格。这在NFT世界是会发生的。
Couldn't the bot just be making a ton of trades with a much smaller amount of money? Maybe the bot's even buying from itself to drive up the price of NFTs. That's something that happens in the NFT world.
肯回信说，也许我是对的，也许不对。不过，他正在获得一个新工具，可以告诉我们所有这些交易背后的钱到底有多少，这样他就能判断自己是否真的认为这是一个犯罪集团在幕后操纵，也能更好地评估他自己面临的风险。
Ken emails back, says maybe I'm right but maybe not. Though, he's getting a new tool that could tell us how much money is really behind all those trades so he could decide if he really thinks it's a criminal syndicate behind all this and get a better sense of how much risk there is for him.
他得到的是一家名为Chainalysis的软件公司开发的产品。它通常被政府、执法部门和金融机构用于追踪谁在NFT和加密货币领域做了什么。它可以告诉肯那个机器人到底在买卖什么，卖给谁，以及它还与其他哪些账户进行了交互。
What he's getting is software developed by a company called Chainalysis. And it's usually used by governments and law enforcement and financial institutions to track who's doing what in NFTs and crypto. It could tell Ken what the bot was buying and selling and to who, what other accounts it interacted with.
“我今天在和Chainalysis的人谈，”肯写道。几天过去了，肯一直在使用Chainalysis工具查看谁买了PixelMap瓷砖，查看机器人在做什么。
"I'm talking to the Chainalysis people today," Ken wrote me. A few days pass while Ken uses the Chainalysis tool to look at who bought and sold PixelMap tiles, look at what the bot was doing.
然后他给我发了短信：“我有很多更新。关于几乎所有事情我都搞错了。”
And then he texts me, "I have lots of updates. I was wrong about pretty much everything."
他发现的情况，以及我和那个机器人——或者说，反正就是机器人背后的人的对话——将在几分钟后，在芝加哥公共广播的节目继续时告诉你。
What he found, and my conversation with the bot-- or anyway, the guys behind the bot-- that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《不情愿的探索者》。我们讲述的是一个发现自己被传送进一个从未要求进入的新世界的人的故事。他决定环顾四周，弄清楚到底发生了什么。我随行见证了这一切。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Reluctant Explorer. We have the story of somebody who finds himself in this new world that he never asked to be part of. And he decides to take a look around to figure out the truth of what is going on. I came along for the ride.
我们现在正处于关于肯·欧文和PixelMap的故事中间。在深入讲述之前，我想也许现在是一个好时机，为所有听到这里仍然确实不知道什么是NFT的人，更详细地解释一下什么是NFT。
We're right now in the middle of our story about Ken Erwin and PixelMap. And before we go further in that story, I'm thinking that this might be a good moment to explain what NFTs are in a little more detail for everyone who's gotten this far in our story and still actually does not know what they are.
好的，那么，NFT是图像、艺术品或视频剪辑，基本上就是你可以发在网上的东西。让它们成为NFT的关键在于，有人可以声称他们拥有它。这种所有权之所以可能，是因为NFT的拥有记录存储在一种叫“区块链”的东西上。
So OK, NFTs, they're images or artwork or video clips, so basically that you can post online. The key thing that makes them an NFT is that someone can say they own it. And ownership is possible because a record of who owns the NFT gets stored on something called a blockchain.
很多人知道什么是区块链，但很多人不知道。所以我只想说，区块链是一组遍布全球的计算机，它们存储着完全相同的数据。任何人都可以查看这些数据。它们就像任何人都能阅读的公共账本。所以区块链存储着谁拥有哪个NFT、谁拥有加密货币的记录。
And lots of people know what a blockchain is, but lots of people do not. So I'm just going to say the blockchain is a set of computers that are all over the world, and they all store exactly the same data. And anybody can look at that data. They're like a public ledger that anybody can read. So blockchains store the records of who owns which NFTs, who owns cryptocurrencies.
而现在，各种各样的人正在发明各种各样的东西扔到区块链上。这真的很乱，很混乱，很无政府主义。一端是NBA在以NFT的形式销售扣篮视频，基本上是在为加密世界重塑体育交易卡，非常老派，非常商业化。
And right now, all kinds of people are inventing all kinds of things to throw up on the blockchain. It's a messy, anarchic chaos, really. One end of things, you have the NBA selling videos of great dunks as NFTs, basically reinventing sports trading cards for the crypto world, very old school, very commercial.
在另一端，有人烧毁了一张班克西（Banksy）的版画，然后以远高于原作成本的价格售出了一份数字副本，比如版画的照片。那件事就像很多加密项目一样，有点像是在嘲弄任何人竟然会认为那个NFT有任何价值的想法。
At the other end, you have stuff like some people who burned a Banksy print and then sold a digital copy of the print, like a picture of the print, for way more than the original ever cost. That one was like a lot of crypto stuff in that it was kind of making fun of the whole idea that anybody would think that the NFT was worth anything.
原始班克西版画上确实有这样一句话。引述：“我简直不敢相信你们这群白痴竟然买这堆屎。”所以，让我们接着刚才的故事继续讲。
The original Banksy print actually had this sentence as part of the image. Quote, "I can't believe you morons actually buy this shit." So let's pick up our story where we left off.
第二幕：在黑猩猩的时代，我是一只猴子。
Act Two, In the Time of Chimpanzees, I was a Monkey.
那你上次通话后搞清楚了什么？
So what have you figured out since we last spoke?
一切，字面上是一切。是的。你想让我演示一下我是怎么发现的吗？
Everything, literally everything. Yeah. Do you want me to show you how I found out?
肯向我共享屏幕，这样我就可以看到Chainalysis软件是如何映射某个人的加密货币交易的。我必须说，这是一个非常令人满意的图表，上面有各种颜色的点，还有连接它们的线和箭头。他花了几天时间调查所有这些交易。
Ken screenshares me so I can see how the Chainalysis software maps somebody's crypto transactions. And I have to say, it is a very satisfying chart to look at, with dots of different colors and lines and arrows connecting them. It took him days to look into all these transactions.
但当他调查清楚后，他终于搞明白了：亚当不是那个机器人。他怀疑的那个有钱人，76人队总裁达里尔·莫雷，也不是机器人。那么机器人是谁？
But when he did, he learned for once and for all, Adam was not the bot. The rich guy he suspected, Daryl Morey, president of the 76ers, also not the bot. So who was the bot?
肯开始查看机器人在做的一切。他发现制作机器人的那个人并没有完全掩盖踪迹。肯发现这个机器人发送钱给的一个地址，和所有其他地址都不一样。
Ken started to look at everything the bot was doing. And he found that whoever made the bot had not covered their tracks completely. Ken spotted this one address that the bot sent money to that was different from all the others.
所以我在这件事上真的非常幸运。
So I got really lucky on this one.
幸运是因为他也发现了同样的地址在一个询问虚假以太币的留言板上出现过。是的，虚假以太币。程序员使用虚假以太币来测试他们正在编写的新代码。
Lucky because he also found the same address on a message board asking for fake Ether. Yes, fake Ether. Programmers use fake Ether to test new pieces of code they're writing.
你永远不会用别人的地址做这种事。你总是用自己的。其实我就用过自己的。
You never do this with someone else's address. You always do it with your own. I actually did this with my own.
这个地址引导肯找到了GitHub上的一个账号。
This address led Ken to an account on GitHub.
GitHub是地球上几乎每个人存储源代码的地方。还有其他竞争对手。但微软现在拥有它。这太棒了。
GitHub is where pretty much everyone on the planet stores their source code. There's other competitors. But Microsoft owns it now. It's wonderful.
那个GitHub账号名称是个相当罕见的名称。然后肯找到了一个同名的推特账号。那个推特用户一定就是机器人。
The GitHub account name was a pretty unusual name. And then Ken found a Twitter account with the same name. That Twitter user had to be the bot.
而且他有一个很酷的头像。是一个戴着头带的小皮卡丘。看起来有点生气。
And he has an awesome little avatar. It's a Pikachu with a little headband belt thing. And he looks a little angry.
肯联系了他，在推特上私信了他。
Ken reaches out, DMs him on Twitter.
我说：我是PixelMap的创造者。如果你有时间的话，我很乐意和你谈谈。当我打字的时候，我快吓疯了。我太兴奋了。
So I said, I'm the creator of PixelMap. I would love to talk to you if you have any time. And when I typed this, I was freaking out. I was so excited.
然后我说：我相对确定你买了超过1000个，只是如果方便的话想和你谈谈。然后加了一个笑脸，因为我觉得——我加笑脸只是为了不吓到他。
Then I said, I'm relatively certain that you bought over 1,000 and just wanted to talk with you if you'd be open to that. And then a smiley, because I was like-- my smiley was just like to not freak him out.
然后那家伙回信了。
Then the guy writes back.
他说：嗯，有趣。我很好奇，你是怎么得出这个结论的？这是一个非常好的问题。所以我说：啊，我在接收和发送资金的机器人账户地址里发现了你的地址。然后我加了另一个笑脸来保持——我不想让他觉得我在威胁他或者——你知道我的意思吗？
So he said, hmm, interesting. I'm curious, how did you come to this conclusion? Which is a really good freaking question. So I said, ah, I found your address connected to the bot account on both receiving and sending funds. And then I added another smiley to keep it-- I didn't want him to think that I'm trying to threaten him or-- you know what I mean?
是的。
Yeah.
肯问那个人他是怎么发现PixelMap并开始那么快买入的。那家伙说他看到了亚当的推特。然后他又问：你是怎么在推特上找到我的？带了一个小问号的笑脸。肯解释了他如何找到他的。
Ken asked the guy how he found PixelMap and started buying so quickly. The guy says he saw Adam's tweet. And he asks again, how'd you find me on Twitter? With a little puzzle smiley. Ken explains how he found him.
然后我想确认一下，我想让他验证我是对的。我说：啊，是你吗？你买了超过1000个？除了他的推特外，和达里尔或亚当没有联系？在这一点上，我心想可能确实没有联系，但我只是再核实一下。
So then I wanted confirmation, I wanted him to validate that I was right. I said, ah, is it you? Did you get over 1,000? No connection to Daryl or Adam other than his tweet? And at this point I'm thinking that there is no connection, but I'm just double checking.
于是他回道：是的，我拥有很多瓷砖，但不知道谁是达里尔。我只是觉得这是一个历史性项目，所以就涌进去了。
So he goes, yes, I own a lot of tiles but don't know who Daryl is. I saw this as a historical project and aped in.
在那之后，非常融洽。他们聊了聊以后合作的可能性。那个人告诉肯他有一个合伙人跟他一起做这一切，并告诉肯怎么联系那个合伙人。他和他的合伙人也同意在我不透露他们真名或录音的前提下和我谈话。
After that, it's very amicable. They chat about collaborating maybe someday. The guy tells Ken he as a partner that he does all this with, tells him how to get in touch with the partner. He and the partner also agreed to talk to me on the condition that I wouldn't give their real names or record their voices.
我们通过Zoom进行了一次会议。机器人背后的这两个家伙住在中东，都在20多岁。虽然当他们打开摄像头时，其中一个说：我知道我看起来不像20多岁。加密货币让你衰老得更快。加密货币的一周就像一年。它是全天候的。发生了很多事。
We did a session over Zoom. The two guys behind the bot are living in the mideast, both in their 20s. Though when they turned on the camera, one of them said, I know I don't look like I'm in my 20s. Crypto makes you age faster. A week in crypto is like a year. It's 24/7. A lot of things happen.
他们都在2016年、2017年进入加密货币圈。其中一个曾通过为《反恐精英：全球攻势》等游戏的玩家出售数字武器来赚钱，开始用比特币进行大量此类交易。然后比特币暴涨。
They both got into crypto in 2016, 2017. One of them was making money selling digital weapons to gamers for games like Counter Strike Global Offensive, started doing a lot of those transactions in Bitcoin. And then Bitcoin blew up.
他们进入了NFT领域，曾为去中心化金融网站做过清算人，就像是加密世界的收债人。他们刚刚推出了自己的NFT交易网站来与Opensea竞争，取名为Golom。他们是《指环王》的忠实粉丝。我问他们关于18.4亿美元交易额的事。他们说他们手里有大约1亿美元用于投资，只是在不断反复使用。
They got into NFTs, were liquidators for decentralized finance sites, which is like being a crypto repo man. They just launched an NFT trading site of their own to compete with Opensea that they're calling Golom. They're big Lord of the Rings fans. I asked them about the $1.84 billion in transactions. And they said they have about $100 million that they invest with, and they just spend that over and over.
当我们谈到PixelMap时，他们完全开启了极客模式。他们装饰了一堆自己的瓷砖。如果你去PixelMap.io网站，你可以看到他们组合了一堆瓷砖拼出了“Golom”，还有一些拼出了“Donda”。他们是侃爷（Kanye）的忠实粉丝。
They totally nerded out when we talked about PixelMap. They've decorated a bunch of their tiles. If you go to the PixelMap.io website, you can see where they combined a bunch of their tiles to write Golom and some others to write Donda. They're big Kanye fans.
这一切，我可以这么说，和肯的想象非常不同，不是由凶残的犯罪集团控制的机器人，也不是亚当·麦克布莱德为了欺诈他而勾结的人。
This is all, can I say, very different from Ken imagined, that the bot was controlled by a murderous criminal syndicate or by somebody in league with Adam McBride, trying to swindle him.
这绝对令人震惊。但最深刻的印象大概就是“佩服”。
It was definitely shocking. But probably impressed was the biggest thing.
佩服是因为当肯找到第一个人的GitHub账号时，他看了他编写的代码。
Impressed because when Ken found the first guy's GitHub account, he looked at the code he'd written.
翻阅他的东西，我心想：这家伙代码写得真好。作为一个开发者，他是个好开发者，我真的超级佩服。所以对我来说，我不知道。他就像是我这类人。
And looking through his stuff, I was like, this guy's got some good code. Like, just as a developer, he's a good dev, just super impressed. So for me, I don't know. He's like one of my people.
这当然在某种程度上让人放心，那是一种“我们想象中的怪物并非真实存在”的感觉。但与此同时——
Which, of course, was kind of reassuring in a small world, the monsters we imagine are not real sort of way. But at the same time--
我老实说，确实有些失望，这听起来很奇怪——我绝对不想被俄罗斯黑手党袭击。但我真的以为我能揭开这个大事件的盖子。我以为那会超级酷。
I would honestly say there was some disappointment, which sounds weird-- I definitely did not want to get attacked by the Russian mafia. But I really thought that I was going to blow the cover on this huge thing. And I thought that was going to be super cool.
是的。能揭露一个巨大的犯罪集团这种想法本身就很令人兴奋。
Yeah. There's something exciting about the thought of like, I'm going to uncover a massive criminal syndicate.
或者至少是像76人队总裁那样的人。是的，那是个更酷的故事。
Or at least like, the president of the 76ers. Yeah, that's a cooler story.
好吧，如果机器人不是亚当，也和亚当没关系，那亚当的目的是什么？他为什么坚持要把PixelMap的价格降得那么低？他是在对PixelMap和其他NFT进行“拉高出货”吗？他知道肯怀疑他是那个居心叵测、搞鬼的两面派吗？
OK, so if the bot's not Adam and doesn't have anything to do with Adam, what was Adam's angle? Why did he insist on lowering the price of PixelMap so much? Was he pumping and dumping PixelMap and other NFTs? And did he know that Ken suspected him of being this two-faced mastermind, up to no good?
从来不知道。我根本没想过，字面上说，根本没想到他竟然在怀疑我。
Never. I had no idea, literally no idea that he was suspecting me.
这当然是亚当·麦克布莱德。当我们谈话时，我详细列举了肯怀疑他的所有事情。我读给他听肯说的那些话，比如肯说只有0.01%的可能亚当不是在刻意宰他。亚当对这些感到非常有趣。
This, of course, is Adam McBride. When we talked, I went into detail about all of the things that Ken had suspected him of. I read him quotes where Ken said that there was 0.01% chance that Adam wasn't deliberately ripping him off. Adam seemed truly amused by this.
这简直太疯狂了，伙计。 [笑声] 太疯狂了。但我明白。我理解他的心路历程。这说得通。但我听到这些时，还是很震惊。我甚至根本没想过要做那种事。
It's just crazy, man. [LAUGHS] It's crazy. But I get it. I understand his thought process. It makes sense. But when I hear it, it's shocking. I wouldn't have even thought about doing that.
当我和亚当交谈时，我惊讶地发现亚当是在把肯拉进那个世界前仅仅六个月才沉迷上NFT的。基本情况是去年三月，一批所谓的“历史性、老式NFT被重新发现，并开始赚大钱。”
I was surprised to learn when I talk to Adam that Adam got hooked on NFTs only six months before he pulled Ken into that world. Basically what happened is March of last year, a bunch of these, quote unquote, "historic, old NFTs were rediscovered and started making tons of money."
我的意思是，这直接翻转了我大脑里的开关，哇塞。就像是，天哪，有金矿。去拿你的铲子。去挖。因为那里有金子。你要做的就是去找到它。
I mean, it just flipped the switch in my brain, like, holy cow. It was literally like, oh my god, there's gold. Get your shovel. Go dig. Because there's gold there. All you got to do is go find it.
接下来的四个月，他说他每天花10个小时通过谷歌搜索“数字收藏品”、“区块链艺术”、“区块链收藏品”等词汇来寻找其他早期NFT。他找到了15或20个似乎可能有效的古老NFT。但他表示，它们大多数在原始编程或其他制作方面存在问题，导致它们不适合今天出售。
The next four months, he says he spent 10 hours a day searching for other early NFTs by googling phrases like digital collectibles, blockchain art, blockchain collectibles. He found 15 or 20 old NFTs that seemed like they might work. But most of them, he says there was some problem in the original programming or whatever they made them unsuitable to sell today.
他确实找到了一些合适的。然后他和朋友发现了PixelMap。从一开始，他们就认为，如果能说服创造者降价，这会是一个巨大的成功。而他们降价那么多的原因？嗯，到那时，亚当已经有了一些经验。
He did find a few that were suitable. And then he and a friend found PixelMap. And from the beginning, they thought it would be a big hit if they could just convince its creator to lower the price. And the reason that they lowered it so much? Well, by that point, Adam had a little experience.
我唯一搞砸的那个NFT重启项目，我们把价格定得太高了，结果失败了。
And the one NFT relaunch I failed at, we set that price too high, and it failed.
是哪一个？
Which one was this?
叫Etherization。
It's called Etherization.
人们买得不够多。
People didn't buy enough of them.
他们买得不够多。
They didn't buy enough of it.
所以他为PixelMap的价格做出了最好的猜测。结果比他之前或之后做过的任何NFT项目都要好。人们简直疯了。
So he made his best guess for PixelMap's price. And it worked out better than any NFT he's done before or since. People just went nuts.
是的，那是一枚火箭，完全是一枚火箭。
Yeah, it was a rocket ship, a complete rocket ship.
你买了多少瓷砖？
How many tiles did you buy?
三个。 [笑声] 我是个白痴。我是个白痴。这很有趣，因为我当时比起赚钱，更多是在追求名声和认可。我甚至不知道该说什么。是的。这更多像是：看，麦克布莱德。他重新发现了这个东西。这太棒了。
Three. [LAUGHS] I'm an idiot. I'm an idiot. It's funny because I was more looking for the fame and recognition than the money. I don't even know what to say. Yeah. It was more about like, look at McBride. He rediscovered this. This is awesome.
好了，澄清一下，他确实靠这个赚了五十万美元，也就是肯作为感谢给他的那笔钱。但他当时并不知道会发生那种事。他说，通常情况下，NFT的创造者什么都不会给他。而且没人给过他接近这个数目的钱。
OK, to be clear, he did make a half million dollars off this, the money that Ken handed him as a thank you. But he didn't know that was going to happen. Usually, he says, the NFT creators give him nothing. And nobody's given him close to this much.
他确实想在NFT领域赚钱。但亚当·麦克布莱德似乎同样想要的是，他想让历史性NFT成为一种流行趋势，让它们获得尊重，并建立一个更大的社区来欣赏它们。这就是他的切入点。
He does want to make money in NFTs. But what Adam McBride also wants, just as much, it seems, is that he wants to make historic NFTs a thing, get them respect, create a much larger community that's into them. That's his angle.
如果他成功了，是的，他会从他个人持有的所有历史性NFT中获利。但这现在也成了他的一种个人使命。他希望历史性NFT被铭记并被重视。
If he succeeds, yeah, he'll make money on all the historical NFTs that he owns personally. But it's also now become kind of a personal mission for him. He wants historic NFTs to be remembered and valued.
正是出于这个原因，他并没有用自己的NFT进行“拉高出货”。没有出货。他仍然持有PixelMap的瓷砖以及他发行的其他历史性NFT。肯确实用Chainalysis工具查看了亚当的交易，证实在他能找到的所有交易中，亚当为他的每个项目都买了几个NFT，然后基本上就一直持有它们。
And for that reason, he's not pumping and dumping with his own NFTs. There's no dumping. He's still holding on to his tiles of PixelMap and the other historic NFTs he's launched. Ken actually looked at Adams transactions with the Chainalysis tool and confirmed that in all the transactions that he could find, Adam buys a few NFTs of each of his projects and then basically just holds onto them.
至于“拉高出货”计划的另一个大特点，即欺骗，我找不到任何亚当撒谎炒作他推广的NFT或虚假承诺人们能赚多少钱的例子。当谈到我采访的律师们关于亚当以特别低价向50个“猿群”成员发布NFT Aether的担忧时——提醒你一下，他们说，基本上，如果人们能得到更低的价格，亚当需要向全世界、向任何可能考虑购买Aether的人披露这一点。
As for the other big feature of a pump and dump scheme, deception, I couldn't find any examples of Adam lying about the NFTs he promotes or making false promises about how much money people would make. When it comes to the other concerns of the lawyers that I talked to about Adam and the way that he released that NFT Aether to 50 of his apes at a special low price-- just to remind you, they said, basically, if people were getting a lower price, Adam needed to disclose that to the world, to anybody who might be considering buying Aether.
好吧，我确实这么做了。像Aether，在我们要进行任何赠品或机会之前，它就已经在推特上了。任何人都可以加入那个Discord。任何人都可以介入。我们需要更多人加入。
Well, I actually do do that. Like with Aether, it was on Twitter before we did any sort of giveaway or opportunity. Anybody could have joined that Discord. Anybody could have gotten in. We wanted more people in.
那根本不是事实。交谈结束后，我回去查看了亚当当时发过的推特。他从没提到过你可以通过参加这个活动获得Aether的极低价格，也没提到他举办过这个活动。
That's not true at all. After we talked, I went back and looked at Adam's tweets from back then. And he never tweeted about the fact that you could get a really low price on Aether by coming to this event, or that he had held the event at all.
事实上，在Discord上，他对他关注者说的话是：“不要发推特或转发给任何人，我想把这个机会留在我们这个社区内部。保密。”他确实在活动发生后发在Medium的一篇文章中提到了这次赠送活动。所以我们又联系上了。
In fact, on Discord, he is saying to his followers things like, "Do not tweet or send this out, I want to keep this opportunity to this community only. Keep it on the down low." He did mention the giveaway in a post that he did on Medium after it happened. So we got back on the line.
嘿，艾拉，你好吗？
Hey, Ira, how you doing?
我很好。你呢？
I'm doing good. How are you doing?
挺好的。记忆真是个有趣的东西，不是吗？ [笑声]
Pretty good. Memory is a funny thing, isn't it? [LAUGHS]
确实是。
Indeed it is.
哦，我们的大脑编织的网，伙计，太有趣了。
Oh, the webs we weave with our brain, man, it is funny.
他告诉我，当他回头看Aether发生的事情时，他意识到那时他看到了一个利用打折的NFT来奖励他Discord群成员的机会，他称之为“Alpha Discord”。
He told me that when he went back and looked at what happened with Aether, he realized back then, he saw a chance to use the discounted NFTs to reward the people in his Discord, which he calls the Alpha Discord.
尽管这是一个公共社区，任何人都可以加入。但当时人们在想：如果我们得不到任何“Alpha”信息，我们为什么要在Alpha Discord里？
Even though it's a public community, anybody can join it. At that point in time, people were like, why are we in the Alpha Discord if we're not getting any alpha?
在NFT世界里，“Alpha”意味着特殊信息、情报、别人还没有得到的东西。
Alpha in the NFT world means special information, intel, stuff everybody else doesn't have yet.
对吧？如果你不提供一些很棒的信息，我们为什么要在这儿？所以我试图奖励那些待了很久的人。
Right? Why are we here if you're not going to give us some awesome info? And so I was trying to reward people who were in there for a while.
他告诉我，这一切都是为了建立一个更大的、重视这些历史性NFT的社区。总的来说，我必须说，亚当没考虑过要披露他为“猿群”成员做的这次特别赠送活动，这恰恰表明他以及整个NFT世界的很多人只是在边走边摸索。每个人都还在摸索哪些法律将适用于他们。
He told me that this was all in the spirit of creating a larger community of people who value these historic NFTs. In general, I have to say, the fact that Adam did not think to disclose this special giveaway that he did for the apes just shows how much he and so much of the NFT world is just making it up as they go along. Everyone is still figuring out what laws are going to apply to them.
比如，当我和亚当交谈时，有一个时刻，我准确地告诉了他律师认为他应该披露多少信息才聪明，以避免诉讼。这对亚当来说是个新消息。
Like, there was this moment when I was talking to Adam where I told him exactly how much disclosure the lawyers thought would be smart for him to do to avoid lawsuits. And it was news to Adam.
不，这建议很好。我听进去了。我想我的行为是恰当的。我认为意图很重要。所以我对自己所做的事感觉相当良好。
No, it's good advice. And I hear it. I think I've acted appropriately. I think intention matters. So I feel pretty good about what I've done.
好吧，那是所有罪犯都会说的话。
Well, that's what all the criminals say.
[笑声] 嗯，走着瞧吧。艾拉，来监狱看我。请你一定要来监狱看我，好吗？
[LAUGHS] Well, we'll see. Come visit me in jail, Ira. Will you please come visit me in jail?
距离我最初给肯打电话已经过去半年了，这半年他一直在他被传送到的那个NFT世界里探索。他的行为越来越像个当地人，虽然还算不上“猿群”，但绝对更“能容忍”这些猿群了。
It's now been a half year since my initial phone calls with Ken, half a year where he's been traipsing around the NFT world that he found himself transported to. And he's acting more and more like a local, not exactly an ape yet, but definitely more ape-tolerant.
NFT在他看来似乎不再那么邪恶了。事实上，他曾经认为最糟糕的事情——那些被炒作的NFT，大家在价格上涨时一哄而上，然后卖出获利，留下一群亏损者——他现在自己也参与其中了，在某些项目上赚了钱，在另一些项目上亏了钱。
NFTs don't seem so evil to him anymore. In fact, the exact thing that he thought was so terrible-- NFTs that get hyped, everybody piles on as the price rises, and then people sell and take a quick profit, leaving lots of losers in their wake-- he's now speculated like that himself, made money on a few things, lost money on others.
他说，对于那些NFT，他认为大多数NFT其实大家心里都清楚价格会涨一阵子然后崩盘。
He says with those NFTs, with most NFTs, he thinks, actually, everybody knows the price is going to go up for a little while and then crash.
每个人都知道这一点，每个人只是都在试图把握时机。
And everyone knows that, and everyone's just trying to time it.
把握卖出的时机。
Time when they'll sell.
如果你把握得好，那你就能做得不错。这确实感觉像个游戏，某种程度上。我在这个领域待得越久，就越觉得我们大家都在赌场。而且因为没有任何规则，所以才公平。每个人都在玩这种套路。我不认为这有什么道德错误。
And if you time it right, then you do pretty well. And it definitely feels like a game, sort of. The more I am in the space, the more it feels like we're all kind of at a casino. And because there aren't any rules, it's fair. Everyone is doing this type of thing. And I don't think there's anything morally wrong with it.
天哪，听听你说的话。
Oh my god, listen to you.
我不认为——
I don't think--
你和你之前简直判若两人。
You are so different than you were.
[笑声] 也许我已经变坏了。
[LAUGHS] Maybe I've been corrupted.
是什么彻底改变了他？整个NFT世界在他意识到自己没被诈骗的那一刻起就开始变得不同了。突然间，他觉得自己并没有降落在一个满是小偷、试图占他便宜的黑暗森林里。
What changed him, exactly? The whole NFT world started to look different to him the moment he realized he wasn't being scammed. Suddenly it didn't seem like he'd landed in a dark woods full of thieves trying to take advantage of him.
是的，在那之前我之所以那么生气，是因为我以为这一切都是内部勾结，亚当一直在骗我。然后发现他实际上把重启这件事做得非常好，他确实是在帮我——
Yeah, the reason why I was so angry until that point was I thought that it was an in-house, that I'd been lied to by Adam this entire time. And then to find out that he actually did a really good job of relaunching it and he actually was helping me--
对。所以你意识到，噢，等一下。噢，不，这个陌生人实际上为我做了件好事。
Right. So you realized, oh, wait a second. Oh no, this stranger actually did something good for me.
是的，而且他甚至没收我钱。是的，我给了他小费。但我知道如果他不存在，我也没法自己想出该如何重启并挂牌PixelMap，我肯定做不到这么好。我不知道——那种事情不是我的专业领域。是的，不，他是认真的。
Yes, and he literally didn't charge me. Like, yes, I tipped him. But I know if he never existed and I somehow knew that I should relaunch PixelMap and list it, I would not have done as good of a job. I had no idea-- anything like that is not my skill set. Yeah, no, he was legit.
肯还遇到了一群像他一样的开发者，他们不是诈骗犯。他们只是为了好玩才买NFT。就好像他找到了同类，整个NFT世界看起来就没那么阴森了。
Ken also met a bunch of developers like him, who weren't scammers. They were just buying NFTs for fun. It was like he found his people, and the whole NFT world seemed less ominous.
这并不是说他看得起大多数NFT，他认为99%的NFT基本上就是垃圾，要么是为了捞快钱而故意设计的垃圾，要么本身就是构思错误的产物。其实，这并非非同寻常的观点。有趣的是，我为这个故事采访的那些最大的NFT爱好者，那些真正热爱NFT的人，他们基本都同意这一点。
Not that he thinks very much of most NFTs, 99% of them, he thinks, are pretty much junk, either intended as junk to make a quick buck or just misconceived ideas in the first place. Actually, this is not an unusual opinion. It was interesting to me that the biggest NFT enthusiasts that I talked to for this story, people who really love NFTs, they pretty much agreed with that.
亚当·麦克布莱德说，今天发布的NFT中99%最终可能都会一文不值。他说大多数人现在可能不应该进入NFT领域。机器人兄弟们给出的数字是90%一文不值。我读到NFT大佬加里·维纳查克（Gary Vaynerchuk）预测98%的NFT会亏钱。
Adam McBride says 99% of all NFTs released today will probably end up being worth nothing. He says that most people probably should not get into NFTs right now. The Bot Guys put the number at 90% worthless. I read that one of the big NFT moguls, Gary Vaynerchuk, predicted that 98% of NFTs would lose money.
肯现在的日子过得很平静，他依然住在原来的那栋房子里，这是一栋有蓝绿色百叶窗、到处都是地精、小玩意和腊肠犬的维多利亚风格建筑。他用PixelMap的钱还清了抵押贷款，给自己买了一台更好的电脑和一辆跑车（他现在觉得他打算把跑车卖了），缴纳了超过一百万美元的税款。
Ken's life these days, he's still in the same house he was before all this, a Victorian with turquoise shutters and gnomes and trinkets and dachshunds everywhere. He's paid off the mortgage with his PixelMap money, bought himself a nicer computer and a fancy sports car that now he thinks he's going to get rid of, paid over a million dollars in taxes.
我问过：你的大部分钱还在以太币里吗？它的价格忽高忽低。他解释说，不，为了安全起见，他已经把一半以上的钱转换成了正规的美元。但他表示，拥有那么多钱并没有真的让他的日常生活发生多大变化。他说他工作得比以往任何时候都多，只不过现在全是关于PixelMap的。
I was like, is most of your money still in Ether, whose price goes up and down? And he explained that, no, he's converted more than half of it into regular US dollars, for safety's sake. But he said that having all that money hasn't really changed much in a day-to-day way. He's working more than ever, he said, except now it's all on PixelMap.
我觉得你处于一种奇怪的境地，你工作生涯的大部分时间都在实际操作，为亚马逊、Snapchat这样的大公司编写代码，人们会使用这些代码，它们在世界各地发挥作用。然后是你构建的这个完全没用的东西——
I feel like you're in this weird situation where most of your working life, you were actually doing things and developing code for big companies, Amazon and Snapchat, and people would use the code, like, it would do stuff all over the world. And then this thing that you build that's completely useless--
我讨厌你。我开玩笑呢。
I hate you. I'm just playing
——对社会没做出什么贡献——
--that doesn't contribute to society really--
不，你没意识到的是，我整个职业生涯都在为无意义的事业做贡献。比如在Salesforce工作时，就是为了确保在黑色星期五那天，你能收到来自百思买（Best Buy）和其他每家公司的垃圾邮件。那就像——
No, what you don't realize is I have been contributing to pointless causes my entire career. So when I worked at Salesforce, it was to help make sure that on Black Friday, you get spam emails from like, Best Buy and every other company. And that's like--
所以你的意思是，你之前是富有成效、对社会有贡献的成员这种想法很荒谬？
So are you saying this idea of before you were a productive, contributing member of society is ridiculousness?
我的意思是我从来都不是一个有成效的成员。
I'm saying I was never a productive member.
但你有没有想过，让你致富的这个东西——
But do you think about the fact that the thing that made you rich is this thing that doesn't--
真的很奇怪，我可能写了大概一百万行代码——我不知道具体多少行，但很多，而PixelMap只有70行。所以写了70行好玩的东西就能这样，确实很奇怪。
It's very odd that I've written probably like a million-- I don't know how many lines, but a lot of lines of code, and PixelMap is 70 lines. So it is very odd that 70 lines that I wrote for fun-- yes, it's very odd.
我想我能描述出的最好方式是，感觉就像在游戏里找到了作弊码，但在现实生活中生效了。就像，你输入了指令，然后突然间，你的银行账户不再是个问题。这非常奇怪。
I think the best way I can describe it is it feels like I found a cheat code, like in a game, but for real life. Like, you type in the thing and then all of a sudden, your bank account isn't an issue. It's very odd.
他每天花在PixelMap上的时间，有几个小时是在Discord上和拥有瓷砖的人聊天。但占用他大部分时间的是，肯正在为PixelMap网站设计一款视频游戏。他在雇佣音乐家、艺术家、游戏开发者和项目经理，同时也自己写很多代码。他一直想做一款视频游戏。
The time he spends working on PixelMap every day, a couple of hours of that is chatting on Discord with the people who own tiles. But what's sucking up most of his time, Ken's designing a video game for the PixelMap site. He's paying a musician and an artist and a game developer and a project manager and doing lots of coding himself. He's always wanted to make a video game.
现在他有奢侈的时间随心所欲地做这件事。他知道这款视频游戏不会给他赚任何钱。但他只是喜欢制造东西。正是这种冲动让他最初创建了PixelMap。
And now he has the luxury of being able to spend as much time as he wants doing that. He knows this video game is not going to make him any money. But he just likes making stuff. That's the impulse that led him to create PixelMap in the first place.
[音乐 - "WHERE AM I" BY DUFFY POWER]
[MUSIC - "WHERE AM I" BY DUFFY POWER]
好吧，我们的节目今天由米歇尔·纳瓦罗（Michelle Navarro）和大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）制作。参与今天节目制作的人包括埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、米歇尔·科米特（Michal Comite）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·纳尔逊（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、劳拉·斯塔切斯基（Laura Starcheski）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Well, our program was produced today by Michelle Navarro with David Kestenbaum. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien and Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天特别感谢凯文·罗斯（Kevin Roose）、蒂莫西·马萨德（Timothy Massad）、豪威尔·杰克逊（Howell Jackson）、马特·莱文（Matt Levine）、亚伦·克莱因（Aaron Klein）、萨曼莎·文图拉（Samantha Ventura）、克里斯·克劳福德（Chris Crawford），以及许多在NFT世界里要求匿名但心里有数的人。这期节目是我们的一位老牌制片人罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）的最后一期节目，她在这里工作了近15年，制作了许多令人难忘的内容，包括我们在BAM的现场演出，以及可能是我做过最喜欢的节目，第129期《汽车》（129 Cars），关于一家汽车经销商试图完成月度销售配额的故事。
Special thanks today to Kevin Roose, Timothy Massad, Howell Jackson, Matt Levine, Aaron Klein, Samantha Ventura, Chris Crawford, and a bunch of people in the NFT world who asked not to be named but who know who they are. This episode right now is our last episode with one of our longtime producers, Robyn Semien, she's been here for nearly 15 years, produced so much memorable stuff, including our live show at BAM and what may be my favorite episode we've ever done, 129 Cars, about a car dealership trying to make its monthly quota.
她凭《怀疑的解剖》（Anatomy of Doubt）为我们赢得了皮博迪奖。她也是我们这里的幕后力量。我们会非常想念她。她要去创建自己思考了多年的新播客系列。我肯定我会一直收听。
She won us a Peabody with her episode Anatomy of Doubt. She's a force behind the scenes here too. She will be very much missed. She's off to create a new podcast series that she's been thinking about for years. I definitely know I'll be listening.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费在线收听我们750多期节目的档案。此外，还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。如果你想找点东西听，上面有海量内容。再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs. If you're looking for something to listen to, there's tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，在进入电台之前，他做了多年的野外生物学家。他曾长期担任简·古道尔（Jane Goodall）的助手。但她解雇了他，因为每当他们潜行靠近一群黑猩猩时，他就会大喊——
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, before he got into radio, he worked for years as a field biologist. He was actually Jane Goodall's assistant for a long time. But she fired him because whenever they would sneak up close to a pack of chimps, he'd yell--
天哪，砰，猿群涌入了。
Oh my god, boom, ape-age.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
[音乐 - "WHERE AM I" BY DUFFY POWER]
[MUSIC - "WHERE AM I" BY DUFFY POWER]
[音乐 - “WHERE AM I”，演唱：DUFFY POWER]